hey how come my penis gets big sometimes
and points up in the air
that's called an erection sometimes i
touch my penis because it feels good
this i think is the single creepiest
thing i've ever seen
so right now dalton school which is a
very posh private school 55
000 a year to attend the dalton school
has been caught uh teaching little kids
to pleasure themselves so it's not
it's not even just the the broader
ideology of
lgbt and the sexual revolution it's
actually instructing them
that it is good to pleasure themselves
so that the director
of health and wellness justine ang
fonte at the at the dalton school
is now being reported by the new york
post uh instructing
six-year-olds during her sex ed class
to to touch themselves because it feels
good there's a slight viewer fewer
discretion
pushed here or you know i would say
maybe uh if you've got kids watching
right now maybe lower the volume for
about
60 seconds or you know skip one two on
there because this is
really really creepy stuff i almost
didn't play it except i think it's
important
to hear what is being taught in first
grade classrooms now
all in the name of the sexual revolution
hey how come my penis gets big sometimes
and points up in the air
that's called an erection sometimes i
touch my penis because it feels good
sometimes when i'm in my bath or when
mom puts me to bed
i like to touch my vulva too you have a
clitoris there kayla that probably feels
good to touch the same way
keith's penis feels good when he touches
it but have you ever noticed that older
kids and grown-ups
don't touch their private parts in
public hmm
they don't that's right keith it's okay
to touch yourself and see how different
body parts
feel but it's best to only do it in
private
well if private parts are so special why
do you cover them up
because they are private silly that's
right kayla
because they are private
this i think is the single creepiest
thing i've ever seen
i i don't think that's an exaggeration
you've got
these little cartoon kitty voices
talking about
it's sex and as woody allen says sex
with someone you love right sex in the
privacy of your own room
and then this teacher saying well it's
good it's okay
it's totally fine to do that in private
but you don't always want to do that
in public now this is part of the sex ed
class at dalton the reason i even play
it is not just how shocking and creepy
it is
but it's to show what this is really
about because the education that's being
conveyed in this video
is not just sexual education there's a
little bit of sexual education here's
this body part here's this buddy part
but it goes much further than that it's
morality education
it's religious education because what
this woman is saying is
look given the laws of our society
it's not okay to do these sorts of
things in public
but it's perfectly okay to do these
sorts of things in private
that's a moral teaching that's a
religious teaching that's not the
christian understanding of it the
christian teaching is it's not okay to
do that in private
jewish understanding as far as i know
i'm no expert not okay to do muslim
understanding it's not okay to do that
in private
but the leftist understanding is it is
okay it's actually good
you should be doing it this goes back
way way far back this goes back almost
100 years
to theorists like wilhelm reich very
creepy
sexual and political theorist who said
that all the problems of the world from
war to disease are caused by a lack of
orgasms
seriously he had he had an orgone
accumulator is what he called it
it was a like an orgasm box where uh
many very intelligent leftists bought
these boxes and sat in them i don't know
what they did
i don't i don't want to know what they
did in those boxes but but these
theories were
very popular bernie sanders adopted them
in the 1960s he wrote creepy essays
about it that he published in the
vermont freeman i think the name is i
actually talked about this at some
length in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
pre-order you get a signed first edition
of premier collectibles there was a
very creepy focus on the need to
sexualize kids and the reason is if you
really believe
that sexual repression is the cause of
all these problems in the world
then you can't wait until people embrace
the oppression you can't can't wait
until people decide they are going to
repress themselves
you've got to get them at their very
youngest point and so you've got to go
into the schools and you've got to
indoctrinate kids in this radical sexual
ideology it's creepy
it's pervy but for the left it serves a
political purpose
so you got the left focusing on this
really really creepy
sex stuff and to give them their credit
it's not just because they're perverts
it does have a political purpose
ginning up lust ginning up
licentiousness
lectures all this sort of stuff is
designed to control you politically and
i know that sounds kind of
conspiratorial but it's actually a very
basic principle
free people cultivate their higher will
and their intellect so they can control
all of their base appetites
unfree people slavish people just
pursue their basest desires whether
that's for drugs
whether that's for sex whether that's
for any any sort of base desire
the example i often use is the heroin
addict the heroin addict who just shoots
up heroin all the time
according to the modern leftist view
seems very free because he can do
whatever he wants and he can go shoot up
and that's nobody's going to stop him
but we all know he's a slave and this is
true of all of our
passions and our lusts especially sexual
ones because
it's a very big driver of human behavior
especially for dudes so the left does
have a vested interest
in breaking down all all these sorts of
um moral codes and the founding fathers
wrote about this right they said
you should not abuse your liberty to
licentiousness
he's very very focused on that sort of
thing and the whole point of pride month
it's not even just a it's not about gay
people really anymore right i mean
i guess that's part of it but it's about
all this sort of sexual stuff
which it actually tends to have a much
broader
point now this is religious education
that people are being taught
it's it's a part of the liturgical
calendar i mean
you've got the religious you know the
christian liturgical calendar you've got
months to the sacred heart of jesus or
the
months to the holy family or what
and in the leftist calendar you've got
months to
pride you've got months to women's
history you've got months to black
history right all these sorts of things
we are following these religious
pathways we're following these religious
longings because man is fundamentally a
religious being and all human conflict
is theological
but some republicans don't get that hold
up
you know what i'm going to say do i even
need to say it you see it it's right
there
it's just that little ding ding ding you
just click it you click you ring the
bell
you like you subscribe you can also
please head on over to the podcast apps
apple podcast google play stitcher
myspace live journal xanga i don't know
and subscribe to the show please leave a
five-star review we really appreciate it
it helps us
get past some of the suppression tactics
of big tech
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you